Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
for my Arrow bonus video I wanted to talk
about Malcolm Merlyn.
John Barrowman has been talking a lot about
how the character is different in Season 3
so I’ll explain what that all means and
count down some of my all time favorite Merlyn
Moments.
The real big reminder is that The Flash is
coming Tuesday October 7th and Arrow Wednesday
October 8th, I’ll be doing videos for all
the episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
If you haven’t seen it, Andrew Kriesberg
who’s an executive producer on Arrow and
The Flash did this featurette where he talks
about the themes of Season 3.
You have to pre-order season 3 on iTunes in
order to get the clip.
I can’t upload it to youtube.
I saw someone tried and they got the ban hammer
from warner brothers.
He explains that from Oliver’s perspective
in season 2 it was “am I a killer” and
in season 3 it’s going to be Identity, “who
am I”.
And that’s going to trickle down to all
the other characters, including Malcolm Merlyn.
Merlyn and Thea find themselves in this interesting
situation where one has lost his child, Tommy
and one lost her mother, Moira.
So you have these two try to figure out how
to form a new family unit with Merlyn’s
past and the league of assassin’s casting
this giant shadow over everything they do.
That’s where the fun starts.
Both Oliver and Merlyn have bottled up a lot
of their demons
and as Kriesberg said, there’s always the
opportunity for those demons to get out.
That’s a very eloquent way of saying Ra’s
Al Ghul, the head of the demon, is also Merlyn’s
Demon.
As well as a demon for everyone.
But during the featurette Kreisberg also referenced
Slade in the Argus prison when he talked about
bottled demons getting out.
I’m not expecting Slade to get out, but
they’ve only shot about half of the episodes
this season.
They haven’t finished writing everything
yet either, so there’s always the opportunity
to bring Manu Bennett back.
The side tangent to the really obvious demons
is Komodo.
We saw him in the season 3 trailer.
He shows up in episode 2.
In the comics he was linked to Oliver’s
father, but since the show changes a lot of
things they might link his backstory to both
Oliver and Merlyn.
At some point Team Merlyn and Team Arrow have
to collide, probably going to be some League
of Assassin’s Ra’s Al Ghul whatnot.
John Barrowman said that Merlyn is a man ultimately
looking for redemption.
And using power to get what he wants ended
in horrible failure, so this season he’s
taking a more personal approach, playing on
emotions.
But all the things he does in season 3 will
be part of that bigger personal
mission of redemption.
I think it’s a really awesome way to think
about the character, it explains why Merlyn
doesn’t think of himself as a villain.
And even though he’s a villain in the comics,
they’ve been able to blur the lines on Arrow.
So you should expect a lot of fun awkward
Merlyn Family Moments with Thea.
I also wonder what his relationship with Oliver
will be like.
Based on the scenes in the trailer it’s
hard to tell when he and Thea come back to
Starling.
It seems like they left town and have been
training somewhere far away.
Generally, we’re going to see more of Merlyn
in his own domain, not being crazy sinister
like in season 1.
Here’s my top 5 Malcolm Merlyn Moments from
seasons 1 and 2.
5 - Merlyn Tells Oliver The Hood Should Change
his name to Green Arrow
This was episode 9 years end from season 1.
Merlyn had just killed Adam Hunt so the Dark
Archer was rearing his head and Oliver was
still trying to deflect attention from The
Vigilante.
This was all before people started calling
him the Arrow.
Merlyn had already suspected Oliver might
be the Vigilante, so they’re all at the
dinner table having a very Hannibal type meal.
Maybe we’ll actually get more of those moments
in season 3.
That would be awesome.
Later in that episode too, Merlyn hands Oliver’s
ass to him.
That was one of their first big fights.
The whole thing is just a big wink at the
comics and I loved that they gave the line
to the big villain of that year.
How great is it that the villain can see into
his future in a way Oliver can’t.
At the time he had no idea what Team Arrow
was going to become.
And he’s just now starting to get into Justice
League mode.
That time when he starts teaming up with bigger
and bigger superheros like The Flash.
4 - Merlyn Throws Down In Front Of Tommy For
The First Time
Wearing a Tuxedo none the less.
This was Season 1 Episode 16 Dead to Rights.
It was fun to see him get his james bond moment.
And it got even crazier because Deadshot was
the one trying to kill him.
Oliver ended up saving his life and that also
became the moment Tommy learned Oliver was
the vigilante.
3 - Malcolm Merlyn Reveals Himself as the
Dark Archer for the first time
This was also from the same mid season finale
in season 1.
It wasn’t a big surprise for comic book
readers, but the way they filmed it with John
Barrowman throwing his hood back and showing
his face for the first time was epic.
2 - Malcolm Merlyn Returns for the First Time
In Season 2
This was from Season 2 Episode 7, the state
versus moira queen.
Merlyn had fixed the trial to get Moira off
the hook.
And he was just beginning to set his Thea
plot into motion.
He was still very much a Season 1 Merlyn.
By the time he came back in the season 2 finale
he was much closer to the Merlyn we’ll see
in season 3.
Less machiavellian but still very dark.
1 - Oliver Versus Merlyn in the Season 1 Finale
Their final battle was one of the best action
sequences all year long and the fight didn’t
really end.
I’m expecting them to pick things back up
where they left off.
At least at first, I think they’ll put their
hatred aside and deal with the bigger threat
together.
I was kind of hoping they’d team up against
slade in season 2, but they might have just
been holding that off till season 3.
Let me know what your favorite Merlyn moment
is and do you want to see him team up with
Oliver against Ra’s Al Ghul this season?
I’m working on a Flash video for tonight,
but tomorrow some special Star Wars stuff
is happening.
And this isn’t happening yet, but I’m
going to be doing a Charity Drive in October
for Charity Water.
I’ll make a special video explaining everything
soon, but until then I’m just going to keep
reminding you guys that it’s coming soon.
It will be a good opportunity to turn all
of our TV watching into some actual social
good.
Right now click here for that Flash Video.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
And Click here to learn about the Arrow Flash
Crossover Episode.
Thanks for watching, let’s all high five
and meet back up tonight for The Flash!